the impeachment trial is almost ready to
begin in the Senate the Democratic race
remains wide open and the women's March
falls apart i'm ben shapiro this is the
ben shapiro show the ben shapiro show is
sponsored by expressvpn protect your
online privacy today at Express at VPN
comm /ban well I hope you got your rest
this weekend because there is a lot of
stuff that is happening this week a
little bit later on in the show we'll
get to these gun rights protests in
Virginia being maligned by the media
we'll get to the women's March but we
begin with your impeachment update so
the New York Times basically admitting
at this point that the Democrats do not
have enough material to impeach report
from the New York Times today Democrats
seek more testimony and evidence for
impeachment trial which sort of requires
us to ask the question why would they
need more testimony and evidence given
the fact that I was informed they had
great testimony and great evidence this
is I was informed of this I was informed
that they had an open-and-shut case so
why do they need more testimony and
evidence I mean they gravely and soberly
and seriously and sombrely announced the
impeachment and then they soberly
seriously sadly walked over the
impeachment charges from the house to
the Senate and I was informed that this
thing was a done deal that basically
they had all the evidence they needed
well now the New York Times is reporting
with president Trump's impeachment trial
getting underway
Democrats are intensifying their demands
for more testimony and documents that
could add to the already voluminous
evidence against him and bolster their
case by shedding new light on several
key questions now as I mentioned last
week this would be about the time where
you should have a complete case you can
call additional witnesses of course the
Senate can do its own investigation all
that is true but the fact that Democrats
are now relying on the Senate
Republicans to do so demonstrates a
giant failure on their own part to
actually do their research to wait for
the proper witnesses does it not near
attempts has despite the White House
strategy of blocking testimony from top
officials and rejecting demands for
documents the Senate will have in front
of it various accounts of how mr. Trump
eagerly sought to persuade Ukraine's new
president to pursue investigations into
two matters that could benefit him in
his re-election campaign those matters
are dealings in Ukraine involving former
Vice President Joe Biden and his 100
button and purported Ukranian meddling
in the American 2016 presidential
election now notice how the new york
times already morphing the charge
originally you wanna know what the
Democrats thought they had go back to
Adam shifts silly fake reading of
president Trump's phone call with
ukrainian President Vladimir once key if
you actually go back and you listen to
what Schiff said what Schiff said is
that Trump had called up szalinski and
then he had said I want you to make up
information about Joe Biden and in
return we want our military aid right
we'll give you the military as long as
you give us some fake information about
your Biden right make up an
investigation just make it up that would
be impeachable that would be a crime
that actually be bribery but they've not
proved any of the elements of that and
so instead they have now broadened this
out so the way the New York Times is
describing the charges now is that Trump
pursued investigations into two matters
that could benefit him in his
re-election campaign okay well again
that standard is too vague as I've been
saying since the very beginning if the
standard for miss fort for some sort of
bad action in in a foreign country is
doing something that theoretically could
benefit you in a reelection campaign
welcome to foreign policy where nearly
every president does something that
could benefit them in their reelection
campaign the question is whether you
violated the law or whether you engaged
in some sort of high-level corruption
according to the New York Times in part
because of the White House's decision
not to cooperate the record of actions
by mr. Trump and his underlings is
riddled with gaps
that's the admission right there that is
the New York Times description phrase
riddled with gaps and new evidence has
been surfacing at the eleventh hour no
there's not been any new evidence
surfacing you have the testimony of some
kook and him glove Parnas who was
according to the USDA Jay working for
Ukrainian oligarch and trying to
manipulate events so that the US
ambassador to Ukraine Murray Ivanovich
should be fired and then he's been going
around on national TV basically lying
about it to the cheers of the media
according to the New York Times
testimony from mr. Trump's senior
advisors could illuminate how overt the
president's efforts were though it is
unclear if that would persuade any
Republican senators who abandon their
defense of the president the the bias in
the media is it's all fake guys it's all
fake
on Sunday representative Adam Schiff the
chairman of the House Intelligence
Committee and the lead house impeachment
manager said he was concerned that the
CIA and National Security Agency were
withholding information about Ukraine
out of fear of angering the president
well the president is the head of the
executive branch the CIA and the
National Security Agency do not actually
work for Adam Schiff Schiff said the NSA
in particular is withholding what are
potentially relevant documents to our
over Cyrus
abilities on Ukraine but also
withholding documents potentially
relevant that the Senators might want to
see during the trial okay well he could
subpoena the documents and then you
could wait for it to be adjudicated by a
court and then they have to turn it over
but they didn't knew that instead they
decided to rush forward with all of this
Senator John Cornyn of Texas said this
to me seems to undermine her indicate
that they are getting cold feet or have
a lack of confidence in what they've
done so far and that of course is
exactly correct now President Trump for
his part has had a couple of his lawyers
in this matter Jay Sekulow and Pat chip
alone he counsels to the president one
to the White House once the president
personally seculars for the president
personally Schiphol onus for the White
House they have issued only a seven-page
response to the articles of impeachment
so the articles of impeachment like a
hundred pages most of it is filled with
stuff that we already know we've gone
through most of it here on the show
Trump is like this thing does not even
meet basic standards of evidentiary
scrutiny and so they issued what
effectively is a seven page rebuttal and
it's just a harsh letter effectively the
letter says the articles of impeachment
submitted by House Democrats are a
dangerous attack on the right of the
American people to freely choose their
president this is a brazen amount and
unlawful attempt to overturn the results
of the 2016 election and interfere with
the 2020 election now just months away
the highly partisan and reckless
obsession with impeaching the president
began the day he was inaugurated and
continues to this day the articles of
impeachment are constitutionally invalid
on their face they failed to allege an
evite crime or violation of law
whatsoever let alone high crimes and
misdemeanors as required by the
Constitution they are the result of a
lawless process that violated basic due
process and fundamental fairness nothing
in these articles could permit even
beginning to consider removing a duly
elected president or warrant nullifying
an election and subverting the will of
the American people and then the the
letter goes on this way that the process
violates all precedent and that the the
articles of impeachment are from fronts
of the Constitution where all of that is
is simply editorializing and it's not
unconstitutional unconstitutional would
be if the Senate with 51 votes decided
to oust the president right that would
be unconstitutional but they cannot
impeach for any reason I mean
impeachment is in fact a political
process and the process in the house was
run like other processes in the house
had been run it was run stupidly
it was running biased fashion partisans
were running the thing but that is not
any surprise at this point chip alone
and in Sekulow go through the charges
they say the first article the article
with regard to abuse of power fails on
its face to state an impeachable offense
it alleges no crime at all let alone
high crimes and misdemeanors in fact it
alleges no violation of law House
Democrats abusive power claim would do
lasting damage to the separation of
powers under the Constitution and they
say that Trump has never in any way
abused the powers of the presidency and
they say that it was a perfect phone
call and all the rest of president
Trump's depends and then they say the
second article of impeachment also fails
to state an impeachable offense this
would be the one about obstruction of
Congress they say to the contrary the
president's assertion of legitimate
executive branch confidentiality
interests grounded in separation of
powers cannot constitute obstruction of
Commerce now they are correct that the
articles of impeachment do not allege
crime now is that the end of the story
of course not I mean the the house the
Senate they can impeach and convict for
any reason whatsoever you don't have to
have a criminal offense but speaking of
precedent has there ever been an
impeachment effort that was not based on
some violation of law not really
not really so that is unique and Trump's
attorneys are right to point that out
okay we'll get to more of this in just
one second Trump has now formed his
legal team and includes a couple of sort
of big names we'll get to that in just
one second first let us talk about how
you can save money quickly and easily
and you can do it for free okay I use
this service it's called honey you
install honey on your computer runs in
the background of your computer and then
it just saves you money like literally
every time you shop it goes online for
you and then it finds all of the
applicable codes and then it applies
them to what you're buying I'd probably
save thousands of dollars at this point
using honey and I did the other day I
went to the MLB store and I bought
myself a Chicago White Sox Jersey and
honey went looking for a code and saved
me a little bit money and a little bit
money adds up the more you purchase I
purchase like everything online it works
on Amazon it works on eBay it works on
pretty much everything that you can buy
online honey has found it's over 18
million members over two billion dollars
in savings
honey supports over 30,000 stores online
including Macy's Target Sephora Best Buy
and more and they're adding more every
day and users love honey and there's a
reason for that because why the hell
wouldn't you I mean it's saving you
money right now using a honey feels a
pretty great think of it as a little
daily victory and making your wallet a
little bit heavier as opposed to making
it a little bit lighter
plus it's free to use it installs in
just a few seconds get honey for free at
join honey calm slash pen that is @j oin
honey
komm so I've been joined honey calm /ban
go check them out right now
okay president Trump has formed his
legal team it includes a couple of heavy
hitters in terms of big names Alan
Dershowitz who's a guest on the show
last week and of course longtime famous
lawyer who has been involved in trials
ranging from the OJ trial to the - to
the trial of a man who is accused of
killing his wife and it wasn't true and
or at least it didn't seem to be true
Durst was involved in a lot of very
famous cases and so bringing him aboard
sort of kids this whole thing the
Hollywood appeal Kenneth Starr has also
joined on and people are going nuts over
this how could Kenneth start at the man
who went after Bill Clinton now be
defending Donald Trump well cuz in the
Bill Clinton trial he actually committed
perjury he's kind of started a full
investigation in uncovered crimes here
are no crimes have actually been
uncovered which is why the articles of
impeachment son included in crimes
nonetheless George Conway who's become
famous simply by virtue of the fact that
his last name is Conway and his wife is
famous and now we are supposed to take
his legal analysis even more seriously
than we would if you were just some
Rando lawyer in the Washington DC area
he has a piece in The Washington Post
today that says this is what happens
when you don't pay your legal bills
President Trump whose businesses and now
campaign have left a long trail of
unpaid bills behind them has never
discriminated when it comes to sniffing
people who work for him that includes
lawyers which is part of the reason he
found the need to make some curious
last-minute tweaks to his team
announcing at the addition of the legal
odd couple Alan Dershowitz and Kenneth
Starr the president has consistently
encountered difficulty in hiring good
lawyers to defend him in 2017 after
Robert Muller became special counselor
counsel Trump couldn't find a high-end
law firm that would take him as a client
his reputation for non-payment preceded
him now he's trying to make up an excuse
Conway for why a big firm wouldn't take
on Trump the answer is a big fun
wouldn't take on Trump because there are
too many lawyers who don't like Trump
and they're afraid of the blowback I get
from their other clients right if Davis
Polk Wright Tremaine had picked up Trump
as a client they would get enormous
blowback from the partners from the
other from the other associates they
don't care about the associates but but
certainly from their clientele this is
okay here's the real reason and Conway
buries it of course being cheap wasn't
the only reason from struck out among
the nation's legal elite there was the
fact that he would be an erratic client
who'd never take reasonable direction
firms also understood that taking on
Trump would kill their recruiting
efforts that would be the actual issue
now left Trump to be person
in the Moller investigation by a random
patchwork of council including jay
sekulow
a lawyer specializing in religious
liberty cases and John's out a
Washington solo practitioner who
according to Bob Woodward viewed Trump
as an effing liar Dowd denies that and
then Trump had the assistance of Rudy
Giuliani contrast that unimpressive crew
with the team assembled by President
Bill Clinton who had not one but two
top-notch law firms defending him global
powerhouse Skadden Arps with heavy
hitter Bob Bennett's handle in Paula
Jones case and the elite Washington
defense from Williams and Connolly led
by the brilliant David Wow so that means
that Clinton was innocent because he got
big-name lawyers to defend him from
well-established firms
either that or immense he was a Democrat
but according to George Conway it's very
bad that Dershowitz and Starr are now
defending the president he says
Dershowitz may be a genius in some ways
but he's not necessarily the advocate
you want on your side judges have told
me they find him condescending in manner
and tone Wow Wow
oh my gosh judges told George Conway a
thing that's crazy and then I love this
as his former Harvard colleague
professor Lawrence tribe has put it
Dershowitz revels in taking positions
that ultimately are not just
controversial but pretty close to
indefensible this would be the same at
Lawrence tribe who spent the last
several years absolutely losing his mind
and he's tweeting garbage that makes no
sense because he has trumped arrangment
syndrome like terminal from derangement
syndrome
George Conway is also very upset with
Kenneth Starr he says I know and like
Starr but I can't comprehend what he's
doing here he's best known as the
independent counsel whose investigation
led to the impeachment of Clinton that's
hardly helpful for Trump because Clinton
was a compared with Trump or
alternatively it's actually good for
Trump because ken starr who knows what
an impeachable offense looks like is
saying this is not an impeachable
offense okay so that is the setup Alan
Dershowitz was on the sunday shows of
making the rounds he made the case that
abuse of power is not impeachable now
here is the reality
anything is impeachable and the media
are of course jumping on this to suggest
that that Dershowitz doesn't understand
what impeachment is that of course is
incredibly silly there's what's fully
understands that you can impeach for any
reason he is just saying that in his
opinion and in the opinion of most
senators if you are going to impeach
somebody you need to allege a crime here
is Alan Dershowitz explaining that just
saying abuse of power does not make does
not make activity impeachable in order
for a president to be impeached and
johnson was impeached on charges that
didn't include criminal conduct he
argued successfully to the Senate that
criminal like conduct is a require that
argument prevailed I will be making that
argument as a lawyer on behalf of the
president's defense team against
impeachment now the media went nuts over
all of this suggesting that Saoirse
what's he's saying something crazy no he
is not he's pointing out a very obvious
truth which is if you're going to try to
impeach a president typically you should
actually register some sort of criminal
activity like an actual crime now last
week they tried to suggest the trumpet
violated the law because the Government
Accountability Office suggested that his
administration had not given a special
message to Congress about why they had
delayed aid to Ukraine but as I
mentioned last week that same statute
has a remedy in the statute for what is
supposed to happen and none of it
actually involves the impeachment of the
President of the United States normally
impeachment is reserved for situations
in which the president commits an actual
crime that would send him to jail like
perjury and then because you cannot
actually charge a president with a
criminal offense then you have to
impeach him in order so that you can
free up that actual prosecution because
then you have basically a constitutional
impasse the same is not true when the
president just violates a law and
there's a natural remedy in the law for
when the President or the executive
branch violate the law which is exactly
what happened in this general in this
Government Accountability Office report
in just a second we'll get to more of
Alan Dershowitz then we'll get to the
Democrats who are being very sober and
serious and somber and fist-bumping each
other on Friday nights seriously on
national TV fist-bumping each other
we'll get to that in just one second
first let's talk about how easy it is to
rack up a big credit card charge like I
said it's very easy unfortunately to
rack up these big credit card charges
and you figure I'll pay for it now and
then I will just repay it later the
problem is that if you wait like a day
extra suddenly you're paying these
exorbitant fees you can bankrupt
yourself this way really really easily
have friends and family who have done
this sort of thing this is why you
should be looking to pay off your credit
card balances and save with a credit
card consolidation loan from light
stream you can roll multiple credit card
payments into just one payment at a
lower fixed rate light streams credit
card consolidation loans have rates as
low as five point nine five percent APR
with auto pay which is a lot lower than
the national average interest rate for
this sort of thing which is over twenty
percent APR plus there absolutely no
fees no application fees no origination
fees no transaction fees no prepayment
penalties the application is quick and
it's easy and you can apply right from
your phone late
shrim believes the people with good
credit deserve a better loan experience
that's exactly what they deliver so this
is not for somebody who's like blown out
your credit and you have zero credit
score and you've really like it's it's
over for you this is for somebody who
has pretty good credit and you just
falling behind on your credit card
payments and now you need to get out
without spending a fortune just for my
listeners apply now and you get a
special interest rate discount the only
way to get this discount is to go to
white stream comm slash Shapiro again
that's Li ght STR II am calm like stream
comm slash Shapiro subject to credit
approval rate includes 0.50% auto paid
discount terms and conditions apply
offers our subject to change without
notice
is it light stream calm / apparel get
all the information and go check them
out if you've fallen behind and you have
a good credit go check them out right
now at light stream comm / bro that's
light stream comm / Shapiro case a Alan
Dershowitz is doing the right thing as a
lawyer he was asked on national TV are
you saying that Trump's phone call was
perfect that Trump never did anything
wrong and Hirsch what's like no I'm not
gonna say that I'm just gonna say this
is not impeachable because the standard
of law is not the president did nothing
wrong the standard of law is impeachable
since brief filed last night says very
clearly the president did nothing wrong
and you're saying you're not willing to
endorse that statement I did not read
that brief or sign that brief that's not
part of my mandate my mandate is to
present the constitutional argument and
if the constitutional argument succeeds
we don't reach that issue because you
can't charge a president with
impeachable conduct if it doesn't fit
within the criteria for the Constitution
okay so he is right about all of this
but the Democrats are already extended
because they got what they wanted right
Nancy Pelosi got up last week and she
said he's how he's impeached for all
time which is very solemn and sober and
sad it was it was a very moving moment
when a bunch of House Democrats who hate
Trump and wanted him heat on day one
were impeaching the president and we
were told that it was very Solomon's
head and sober so Nancy Pelosi shows up
on Bill Maher to be solemn and sad and
sober wearing her gold LeMay outfit
leftover from the Oscars and here's
Nancy Pelosi sitting with Bill Maher and
fist bumping him physically fist bumping
him over impeaching the president
because obviously this is a sober sad
solemn occasion thank you so much for
waiting till we got back on the air
before you started the Mt
yeah and she's happy and he's happy and
everybody's happy because the
president's impeach and it's so solemn
and so remember that time when she said
it was super sober and she was saving
the Constitution and look at her she is
so how do you take these folks seriously
it's it's nearly impossible to take
these folks seriously then you have Adam
Schiff who's trotting out there
suggesting that he's out there to
protect the Constitution after several
years of lying about having secret
information that would tied Trump to
Russia in such a way that Trump would be
impeached over the Mobil report that
ended up being a complete dud and so
Adam Schiff just moved right on to
Ukraine and then he goes on national TV
and he suggests that when Dershowitz
says abuse of power is not impeachable
no abuse of power would have appalled
the founders
tell me more about appalling the
founders dude who literally spends his
days camped out outside the CNN tent
views of power is at the center of what
the framers intended an impeachable
offense to be the logic of that
absurdist position that's being now
adopted by the president is he could
give away the state of Alaska he could
withhold execution of sanctions on
Russia for interfering in the last
election to induce or coerce Russia to
interfere in the next one that would
have a pall the mere idea this would
have appalled
the founders who were worried about
exactly that kind of solicitation of
foreign interference in an election for
a personal benefit there's nothing I
like more than a man who lied about
Trump and Russia going on TV and
maintaining that he didn't lie about
Trump in Russia and then Trump and
Russia were actually in cahoots to skew
the last election and if we don't
impeach him now Trump's gonna do the
same thing again very very trustworthy
folks I mean while the Democrats are
trying to figure out exactly how they're
gonna thread this whole witness needle
in the impeachment because here's the
problem if they call somebody like left
harness if they try to bring in a
witness like lab partners who as we
discussed last week is this Ukrainian
operator who ordered this American
operator in Ukraine who is dealing on
behalf of the Ukrainian oligarch and
violating law in the process and then
under indictment for falsifying
documents and lying to the federal
government he's going around on the
media and blaming Trump for all of his
Mis action for all of his malfeasance if
Democrats call that guy is pretty
obvious that hunter Biden is also gonna
be called and that ain't gonna go well
for hunter Biden cuz it turns out that
hunter Biden is utterly unqualified for
anything except being the name
a janitor and he's been using his
daddy's last name to fly around the
world picking up bags of cash
okay so sherrod Brown the senator from
Ohio he was he was on CNN over the
weekend suggesting that partners should
testify but hunter Biden is not relevant
so somehow harness is deeply relevant
but hunter Biden whose activity in
Ukraine lies at the very center of
President Trump asking the Ukrainians to
investigate hunter Biden that would be
irrelevant according to sherrod Brown I
assume we want him to testify I know we
want Bolton I know we want people who
are in the room I don't have strong
feelings yet until I hear from the house
managers and what they want to see but I
assume why not have witnesses that that
have a lot of information about this so
I think part us makes sense okay and
then he says he wants he wants lab
partners to testify but hunter Biden I
guess will come I mean if we have to but
why would we even want to talk to hunter
Biden the persons whose activity led off
this entire debacle here is sherrod
Brown again saying yes I'm Webb Parnas
but a 100 and I guess we'll do it if we
have to but like is he really relevant
guys we take the position that we want
to hear from witnesses i I don't know
what hunter Biden has to do with the
phone call you're fine hearing from him
or the I'm fine with hearing I mean I
understand I yeah I'm not a lawyer I
understand both sides get to call
witnesses I'm not sure that a lot of
Republicans think I mean I think many
Republicans think that's a distraction
by the way Bernie Sanders is putting out
notices today in advance of Iowa he
literally just put out his campaign put
out what they called the Burnet notice
it says Joe Biden has a big corruption
problem so the real reason Democrats
don't want hunter Biden testifying is
because it might actually show that
President Trump his suspicions were not
completely unfounded that hunter Biden
was simply serving as a bagman for
himself and using Joe Biden's last name
in order to do so meanwhile the same
Democrats who are suggesting that we
must must must have witnesses back in
1999 we're suggesting that we should
have no it nough says now I think we
should have as many witnesses as we want
I don't really care I think we should
have as many witnesses well I'm not
gonna stand here and pretend that I
think that it's that it is a good policy
to prevent witnesses from testifying in
the Senate impeachment trial I think the
American people deserve to know what
happens in nearly every aspect I think
transparency is good
I do but the Democrats don't think so
back in 1999 one day before President
Clinton was acquitted in his impeachment
trial before the Senate Chuck Schumer
who's now the Senate Minority Leader and
a passionate letter outlining why the
process had taken unfair toll on the
nation according to the New York Post he
noted that the president believed he had
not crossed the line
he praised the large threshold needed to
get a conviction in the Senate and then
he went on record suggesting that the
whole thing had been a giant waste of
time he said it has shaken me that we
stand at the brink of removing a
president not because of a popular
groundswell to remove him and not
because of the magnitude of the wrongs
he's committed but because conditions in
the late 20th century America have made
it possible for a small group of people
who hate Bill Clinton and hate his
policies to very cleverly and very
dogged ly exploit the institutions of
freedom that we hold dear and almost
succeed in undoing me undoing him he
says if you had asked me one year ago if
people like this with such obvious
political motives could use our court to
play the media and tantalize the
legislative branch to achieve their ends
of bringing down the president's I would
have said not a chance that doesn't
happen in America but it almost happened
and they says what Bill Clinton said was
wrong and arrogant we all agree we're
all angered but let's express some
sympathy and now you've got Chuck
Schumer leaving up the mob against Trump
on this without actually advocating a
crime that was actually committed pretty
amazing stuff from Chuck Schumer going
all the way back to 1999 meanwhile Jerry
Nadler is really objecting to hunter
Biden being caught of being called he of
course is the head of the House
Judiciary Committee so Jerry Nadler head
of asks you to share a committee very
much in favor of calling people like Lev
Parnas who suggests he would like to see
called now he says that we should not
even request hunter Biden testify
because that is doing Trump's dirty work
this whole controversy about whether
there should be witnesses is just as
really a question of does the Senate
want to have a fair trial or do they or
are they part of the cover-up the
president any Republican senator who
says there should be no witnesses or
even that witnesses should be negotiated
is part of the cover-up did the
president as we say as the evidence
shows they did betray his country by
conspiring the foreign country to try to
read the election under bite there's
nothing to say about that
they're asking for hunter Biden is just
more of a smear of hunter Biden that the
president is trying to get the Ukraine
to do so yes
mrs. but not those witnesses guys we
can't on those witnesses those would be
bad witnesses meanwhile Adam Schiff was
asked about love Parnas his credibility
and he won't even answer but there he
thinks that love Parnas is credible but
we should call them anyway so no one
Hunter Biden but yes and left Parnas who
is currently under indictment for lying
to the federal government and falsifying
documents is the fact with many of the
people surrounding the president that
they end up indicted these are the
people that the president has chosen to
work with people like you know Michael
Cohen like Lev para nós like so many
others palmat afford and these are
people that do have information about
the president's misconduct but right now
George we don't know what witnesses will
be allowed and even if will be allowed
witnesses we can't really make a
determination on which witnesses will
call in the absence of knowing whether
the Senate will allow any at all so
again Lev partes maybe 100 biden really
not chris wallace went after Hakeem
Jeffries the the Democratic Congress
person from New York over the weekend on
Fox News he said listen you guys keep
talking about how you want more
witnesses and more witnesses and more
witnesses and then you say you have an
open-and-shut case so which is he you
got to pick one what we proceeded
expeditiously because you know Trump's
abuse of power his pressuring of a
foreign government in this instance for
his own personal political gain related
to an urgent matter of national security
you know the notion of withholding 391
million dollars that was allocated but
again you can't have it both ways
congressman you say it was an urgent
matter it was a threat and then Nancy
Pelosi waited a month to even hand over
the articles of impeachment yet I'm glad
you raised that because two parts to
this process I'm glad I'm glad you
raised that but I'm not really that glad
you raised that Chris Wallace cuz this
whole thing is awkward so how long is
this whole thing gonna take according to
Ted Cruz you could take six to eight
weeks in reality it's only gonna take a
couple of weeks I do not think this is
gonna drag out for more than a month I
think by the time we are midway into the
Democratic primaries this thing will be
over speaking of which the 2020
Democratic presidential race continues
apace President Trump has a very simple
case to make he continues to make it
strongly which is that the Democrats are
too far left to be trusted with power
especially given a strong economy the
Democrats have pledged to take economic
measures that will absolutely stop the
longest now longest recovery in the
history of the United States and a
recovery that is picked up
pase under President Trump is very slow
under Barack Obama it picked up pace
under President Trump including
increases in wages at the low end of the
income spectrum here's President Trump
going after the Democrats the far left
they want to massively raise your taxes
crush your your businesses with
regulations take away your health care
and send bureaucrats to interfere with
your property and second guess every
decision that you make the radical left
in Washington wants to demolish these
games and they frankly want to destroy
your way of life they are not for the
farmer they are not for our military
okay what he is saying here is going to
be his campaign and it's the right
campaign and in fact is the Democrats
are split they're not sure which way to
go do they move into the sort of more
mainstream directions they try and grab
that middle voter or they skew to the
left that split was reflected by the
editorial page of the New York Times
which hilariously today issued their
endorsement in the Democratic primaries
and they chose two people two people
which is super exciting stuff
they chose two people Amy Klobuchar and
Elizabeth Warren truly so if you're
wondering how to spend both your votes
now you know you can vote once for an
Elizabeth Elizabeth Warren and once for
Amy Klobuchar what actually happened
here what actually happened here is they
desperately wanted to endorse Elizabeth
Warren but they also recognized that
they would have been viewed as hacks on
behalf of Elizabeth Warren which they
are and so they decided to also endorse
a person who has no shot at winning the
primaries Amy Klobuchar so they could
cover their ass that's really what
happened here in the init Oriole
boardroom it was we could endorse
Elizabeth Warren but we've been busy
kissing her ass for the for the last
year and it's gonna look kind of
ridiculous if we now endorse her
so let's endorse somebody who's not like
an actual mainstream competitor wend or
somebody who looks a little bit more
moderate and we can say that it's all
about female power and then will endorse
Amy Klobuchar now all I can envision is
the editors of the New York Times
breaking a pool cue tossing it between
Amy Klobuchar and Elizabeth Warren and
saying we're having tryouts but with
that said it's pretty hysterical and the
editorial itself is really really funny
it's funny because what they think of as
qualities of these candidates are just
bizarre
they're just bizarre by the way the New
York breaking news the
time's has now suggested at both the San
Francisco 49ers and the Kansas City
Chiefs will win the next Super Bowl
according to the New York Times American
voters must choose between three sharply
divergent visions of the future the
incumbent president Donald Trump is
clear about where he is guiding the
Republican White nativism at home is
that really what really that's what he's
been clear about that if you vote for
Trump your white nativist now that's the
way this is working how about all the
minority people who are voting for Trump
there are many of them it is it possible
that maybe the New York Times is sort of
pigeonhole a what they think from voters
are into a box and they say an America
first unilateralism abroad brazen
corruption escalating culture wars the
judiciary sticks with ideologues and the
veneration of a mythological past or the
hierarchy in American society was
defined and unchallenged by the way when
we speak about mythological histories
the New York Times his mythological
history and the 16:19 project is utterly
astonishingly bad so much so that it was
ripped by professional historians
ranging from James Macpherson to Gordon
wood it takes a lot of gall to suggest
that the traditional history of the
United States is somehow a a myth while
their version of the United States which
the United States was rooted in racism
white supremacy slavery sexism and
bigotry and that everything in US
history has been an outgrowth of that
except for the times when we overthrew
the the principles for just one second
and then went right back to our racism
and bigotry it takes a lot of gall for
people who push that agenda to suggest
that history is being rewritten by Trump
they say on the Democratic side an
essential debate is underway between two
visions that may define the future of
the party and perhaps the nation some in
the party view President Trump is an
aberration and believe that a return to
a more sensible America is possible then
there are those who believe that
President Trump was the product of
political and economic systems so rotten
they must be replaced the Democratic
primary contest is often portrayed as a
tussle between moderates and
progressives to some extent that's true
but when we spent significant time with
the leading candidates the similarity of
their platforms on fundamental issues
became striking okay that part is true
that a lot of these so-called moderates
in the Democratic Party are actually the
same as the progressives when it comes
to policy we'll get to the rest of this
idiotic New York Times editorial
endorsing both Amy Klobuchar and
Elizabeth Warren which is super
unhelpful wait till you get their
description of Elizabeth Warren is
wonderful we'll get to that in one
second first I need to talk to you about
an issue that's been incredibly
important to me for a very long time if
you're
regular listener you most likely heard
me heard me talk about my ardent support
for the pro-life cause I've not been shy
about this you may also remember that
last year I streamed this podcast live
from the March for Life in Washington DC
which is the biggest pro-life rally in
the country or I also gave a speech to
the crowds marching for the cause well
you may not be aware of is how much
grief this caused us from our political
adversaries our advertisers were
targeted by left-wing media watchdogs
several of them actually pulled their
ads from our show under pressure even
though I'd said absolutely absolutely
nothing objectionable this wasn't the
first time nor will it likely be the
last time that we are attacked in an
attempt by the left you shut down a
pro-life of voices we're also not the
only targets live action is one of the
biggest of voices in the pro-life
movement I personally give money to live
action I think they're wonderful that
continues to do some of the most
important work in the space from losing
raising awareness and education on the
abortion issue to undercover videos that
expose Planned Parenthood and other
abortion clinics for horrific human
rights abuses live action has been
targeted a lot on social media they've
been banned from advertising on Twitter
for their calls to defund Planned
Parenthood they've been banned from
Pinterest altogether for quote spreading
a medical misinformation they've seen
their advertising efforts and their
online distribution restricted depending
on the platform and this cause he's
supremely important since the passing of
Roe vs. Wade the creation of Roe vs.
Wade over 60 million preborn children
had been killed in the womb 60 million
kids who never had a chance to give the
world their love and countless young
women harm physically and emotionally
last year the left went even more insane
they passed the New York law allowing
abortion up to birth the Illinois law
allowing partial birth abortion this
year
virtually every Democratic candidate
basically everyone except for Tulsi
Gabbard supports no restrictions on
abortion which is the most radical
position threatening the right to life
that is why our daily wire.com members
are really important why well your
membership keeps our cameras on our
microphones turned up also your direct
support helps us say no to advertisers
who cave to left-wing ideologies you
keep us and our message from being
cancelled and you help the conservative
pro-life movement get louder which is
why from now until January 31st only
right just for the next couple of weeks
a portion of any daily wire.com
membership purchase will be donated to
live action with promo code live action
so when you use that promo code live
action you get our membership we're
gonna donate part of that to live action
the portion will go to support awareness
and education around the world on the
pro-life issue so join us here at Ailey
where DICOM make your pro-life a voice
even louder and protect the cause has
that you care about from the viciousness
of
left-wing that seeks to silence we are
the largest fastest-growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
so to continue at this New York Times
editorial they endorsed both Amy
Klobuchar and Elizabeth Warren they say
many Democratic voters are concerned
first and foremost about who can be mr.
Trump with a crowded field and with
traditional polling in tatters that
calculation calls for a hefty dose of
humility about anyone's ability to
foretell what voters want so that is the
the neuro Times throwing its hands in
the air and saying yeah we know
Elizabeth Warren isn't super electable
but we like her we like her choosing who
should face off against mr. Trump also
means acknowledging that Americans are
being confronted with three models for
how to govern the country not two
Democrats must decide which of their two
models would be most compelling for the
American people and best suited for
repairing the Republic the party's large
and raucous field has made having that
clean debate more difficult with all the
focus on personal characteristics age
race experience and a handful of the
most contentious issues voters have not
benefited from a clarifying choice about
the party's message in the election and
the approach to governing beyond it it
was a privilege for us on the editorial
board to spend more than a dozen hours
talking to candidates asking them any
question that came to mind yet that
exercise is impossible for most
Americans now is the time to narrow the
race that's why we're endorsing the most
effective advocates for each approach
they're not gonna make up their minds on
which approach is better the sort of
return to normalcy approach or the let's
rip everything down approach their
Elizabeth Warren and Amy Klobuchar
Wow amazing they say said and then they
explain why they will mount endorse
Sanders they say senator Sanders to
spend nearly four decades advocating
revolutionary change for a nation whose
politics often move with glacial
slowness Mr Sanders would be 79 when he
assumed office and after October heart
attack his health is a serious concern
then there's how Mr Sanders approaches
politics he boasts that compromise is in
a flood of him only his prescriptions
can be the right ones even though most
are overly rigid untested and divisive
he promises that once in office a
groundswell of support will emerge to
push through his agenda three years into
the Trump administration we see little
advantage in exchanging one over
promising divisive figure in Washington
for another by the way Bernie Sanders
wins the nomination I'm gonna throw that
line back in their face the moment they
endorse Bernie Sanders say good news
then that Elizabeth Warren has emerged
as a standard bearer for the Democratic
Left their description of Warren is just
phenomenal here it is
senator Warren is a gifted storyteller
that is one way of saying a congenital
wire a
gifted storyteller you know telling
stories about her time wandering the
plains with the Cherokee people stories
about how she was fired for the sin of
being pregnant when all documentary
evidence shows that she was actually
unanimously requested to retain her job
all of her stories about her
difficulties in life what a difficult
life she's led how many stories have we
debunked about Elizabeth Warren on the
show 510 if she just says things that
are not true on a routine basis but
she's a gifted storyteller guys a gifted
storyteller
wouldn't you want Elizabeth Warren
telling you a story no you wouldn't
because you're a sentient human well I
guess you're not on the New York Times
editorial board she speaks elegantly of
how the economic system is rigged
against all but the wealthiest Americans
and of our chance to rewrite the rules
of power in our country as she put it in
a speech last month in her hands that
story has the passion of a convert a
longtime Republican from Oklahoma and a
middle-class family whose work studying
economic realities left her increasingly
worried about the future of the country
by the way who work on bankruptcy is
largely bullcrap David French has
debunked it the the idea that people are
on mass suffering from medical
bankruptcy it's just not true
the way that she actually classified
those studies is she said if you went
bankrupt and you had a medical bill she
called that a medical bankruptcy the
word rigged according to their New York
Times feels less pom pastic than rooted
in an informed assessment of what the
nation needs to do to reassert its
historic ideals like fairness generosity
and equality and then they go on to talk
about how she has so many plans miss
Warren accurately describes a lack of
housing construction as the primary
driver of the nation's housing crisis
and she has proposed both increases in
government funding for housing
construction and changes in regulatory
policy yes because the government
housing has always been a boon to the
American people building the projects
has always worked out just phenomenally
and they talk about how she's just gonna
spend enormous amounts of money they
never talked about he's gonna pay for
any of this they never talk about how
she's gonna do any of this but she is
the best they say and then they say but
we have a problem
American capitalism is responsible for
its share of sins but Miss Warren often
cast the net far too wide placing the
blame for a host of maladies from
climate change to gun violence at the
feet of the business community when the
onus is on society as a whole this
country needs a more unifying path okay
and that is why we have
also decided to talk about Amy Klobuchar
ooh
Amy Club tribe first they dismiss Pete
Budaj edge they say that that we look
forward to him working his way up which
is the worst cutting ever Oh P you're so
cute next time around people judge
andrew yang they say he has virtually no
experience in government we hope he
decides to get involved in New York
politics and then they say that Michael
Bloomberg is very bad why he's a
multi-billionaire he's very bad and they
say that his current campaign approach
reveals more about America's a broken
system and his likelihood of fixing it
and then they say that Joe Biden is
prone to verbal stumbles but it is time
for him to pass the torch to a new
generation of political leaders nothing
says passing the torch to a new
generation of political leaders like
being 77 and passing the torch to
somebody who's 70 Elizabeth Warren is 70
years old so there's that and then they
talk about Amy Klobuchar good news that
an Amy Klobuchar has emerged as a
standard bearer for the Democratic
Center her vision goes beyond the
incremental given the polarization in
Washington and Beyond the best chance to
enact many progressive plans could be
under a Klobuchar administration the
senator from Minnesota is the very
definition of Midwestern charisma grit
and stick-to-itiveness her lengthy
tenure in the Senate and bipartisan
credentials would make her a deal maker
a real one and United for the wings of
the party and perhaps the nation so why
didn't they just endorse her outright
well apparently they didn't endorse her
outright because she treated her staff
badly they're gonna go with the she eats
salad with a comb story to not endorse
her over Elizabeth Warren that's
literally the only and then they say she
doesn't have the polished veneer and
smooth delivery that comes from a
lifetime spent in the national spotlight
she struggled to gain traction on the
campaign trail but she's really popular
in Minnesota and they basically say well
no matter who we endorse it's better
than Trump miss Klobuchar miss Warren
right now are the Democrats best
equipped to lead that to make may the
best woman win and then they toss that
that Joker pool cue right between them
and say go for it so who you got Amy
Klobuchar went to comb or Elizabeth
Warren with the knife she just removed
from Bernie Sanders his back meanwhile
the race moves forward a pace Bernie
Sanders who a new poll shows actually in
second place in Iowa there are three new
polls in Iowa all of them showing Bernie
Sanders dropping
behind Joe Biden if Joe Biden by the way
wins Iowa this thing is basically over
before it begins
and that New York Times endorsement
doesn't mean Jack and now Bernie Sanders
is out there on the apology tour trying
to explain to women that gender remains
an obstacle for women in politics yes to
pay homage to the intersectional notion
that women are greatly victimized in
American politics despite the fact that
Hillary Clinton was propped up as a
political figure despite having no
political experience running for the
Senate and then she was a horrible
Secretary of State and then she was a
horrible presidential candidate twice
and we're still being told the only
reason she lost is because of the
Russians here's Bernie Sanders
explaining it's rough to be a lady do
you think that gender is still an
obstacle for for a female politician
look I think the answer is yes but I
think everybody has their own sets of
problems are I'm 78 years of age that's
a problem there are a lot of people say
wow yeah I like Bernie's nice guy but he
is 78 years of age and so we have to
argue please look at the totality of Who
I am
if you're looking at Buddha judge he's
young guy and people will say well he's
too young to be President you look at
this much as a woman you know look at
this you know so everybody you know
brings some negatives if you like me
Bernie has to say that part about how
you're really disadvantaged at Fairleigh
my favorite is the lady asking him the
question he says is it hard to be a
woman and she's trying to Telegraph in
the answer is actually nodding as she
utters the question look the reason that
Bernie Sanders by the way if he doesn't
win the nomination and if he doesn't win
the presidency the reason he doesn't is
because he's a crazy communist that's
why yeah john cusack
out on the road stumping for him because
nothing says connection with the
american people like john cusack
explaining this very wealthy actor we
have 10 years to save the planet from
capitalism
10 years to save the planet from the
greatest force for human prosperity in
the history of the world by was looking
up these statistics yeah there's some
I'm writing a book that would stew out
late July I believe and I was looking up
the statistics on the growth of global
GDP the growth of global GDP so the
growth of global GDP from like 1800 to
2015 it increased global GDP not
American GDP global GDP increased by
fifteen thousand seven hundred percent
in the previous millennia okay in like
the last two millennia before that
increased by the 100 percent and then
the Enlightenment and free markets
happen and boom prosperity but according
to John Cusack I'm gonna take his word
over the experience of the last couple
of centuries he explains we have 10
years to save the planet from capitalism
or we're all gonna die or something
we know this form of capitalism takes
and takes it takes whatever whenever
however it wants it'll take our lives
it'll take our labor our spirit our air
and water even our earth and Bernie
respects us enough to tell the truth
it's a hard truth we have a 10 to 12
year window to radically transform our
energy systems or climate change
predatory capitalism and the endless war
economies will rob us over the right to
any future at all so um no that is that
is why Bernie Sanders has trouble
because in the end Bernie Sanders is a
radical meanwhile get Elizabeth Warren
who's just as radical but the Democrats
are gonna pretend that she's a moderate
explaining that Trump has nominated
racist sexist bigoted homophobic
anti-trans judges yeah I think what's at
the heart of it is who you asked to be a
judge who you want on your list to be a
judge and I'll tell you what the answers
been for Donald Trump cuz I've seen
these guys homophobic that's in racist
that's in sexist oh yeah most definitely
and anti voter that's been a big
qualification he has named one person
after another so that they're all
they're all vicious brutes vicious
brutal racists these are the Democrats
for you good luck with dad this is why I
Joe Biden in two recent polls the last
two polls and I was now up by six in
that average okay time I want to talk
for a second about the media's
contrasting coverage you wonder whether
the media are biased just take a look at
the Virginia gun rights rally that is
happening today now there's a lot of
talk about the Virginia gun rights rally
being infiltrated by Kooks and white
supremacist hey this is a real concern
whenever you have a very very big rally
you have to worry that there gonna be
some fringe people who try to glom onto
the size of the rally and then the media
will cover those people and pretend that
the rest of the rally doesn't exist okay
this is not like the unite the right
rally which is openly openly marketed in
Charlottesville as a white supremacist
rally this is not that okay this thing
is marketed as a pro-gun rally and
bioavailable evidence it is a pro-gun
rally thousands tens of thousands of
people apparently showing up at the
Virginia capital to protest the removal
of gun rights in the state of
and doing so peacefully there they're
like chanting the pledge of allegiance
and members of the media are just lying
about them openly lying suggesting it's
a white supremacist rally it is not a
white supremacist rally and just because
you can find a couple of white
supremacists you try to infiltrate the
rally because they know they'll get
media coverage that way that does not
make the entire rally white supremacists
anymore and a couple of Antipa members
infiltrating the women's March makes it
a terrorist rally that's not the way
this works rally should try to do a good
job of policing who shows up at the
rallies but you can't slander the entire
rally because five guys in Nazi hats it
show up in this case there's not even
been any evidence of that thus far and
yet the media are portraying this as a
terror rally seriously like Gabe
Gutierrez over at NBC News tweeted out a
video of people literally chanting the
Pledge of Allegiance and each and he
tweeted chance of we will not comply
from gun rights protesters in Richmond
they're literally chanting the pledge of
allegiance and you can hear it and he
just lies about it and that's not the
only lie being told yet a couple of
other reporters suggesting that it was a
terrorist rally saying that carrying
guns openly in Virginia which is legal
that this is somehow a violation of the
Second Amendment is not what the
founders intended when it was literally
what the founders intended the coverage
of the Virginia gun rights rally is
astonishingly bad awful so far I know
the media would love they would love
nothing better many of them you love
nothing better than a Charlottesville
leg scenario where a bunch of white
supremacists show up and start killing
people that would be their favorite
thing ever because then it could claim
that all gun rights advocates in the
United States are actually vicious
violent racist brutes that would be
their favorite thing in the world it
hasn't happened yet Bennie Johnson over
at CP USA who's there covering this
thing it says no riots no violence no
targeting of citizens no attacking cops
just thousands upon thousands of
peaceful law-abiding citizens gathering
in Virginia's capital to protest and
unconstitutional assault on their rights
and that of course is exactly that's
exactly right that's exactly right it's
amazing I mean they're really spending
and they're really spending their day
trying to suggest that this thing is
terrorism it's it's not but they did the
same thing with the Tea Party the Tea
Party was apparently terrorists and
racist despite no evidence that it was
terrorists or racist meanwhile the
women's March which was run for years by
open anti-semites here's how that was
covered over the weekend so nobody
showed up
isabella gomez Sarmiento reported from
NPR quote women's March draw see smaller
but passionate
crowd the 4th annual women's March
descended on the streets of Washington
on Saturday unlike the first
demonstration that brought hundreds of
thousands to the capital the day after
president Trump's inauguration the March
drew just a fraction of the original
turnout as the movement has struggled
with changes in leadership and questions
about inclusivity but they were
passionate they were so passionate and
that's what really mattered the permit
only allowed up to about 10,000 people
by the way the permit filed with the
National Park Service but it was
passionate guys so the media say that
the women's March passionate passionate
but small the gun rights rally march
large and terrorists and white
supremacists no evidence of terrorism or
white supremacism welds on media this is
what you guys do ok time for a quick
thing that I like and then a quick thing
that I hate and we will get out of here
because we have two more hours of stuff
to do later ok things I like over the
over the weekend I was reading some of
my one of my favorite authors Ray
Bradbury
so Bradbury of course is known for
Fahrenheit 451 one of the great American
novels he's also a terrific little
horror writer when I say little I just
mean in terms of short stories he wrote
like 300 300 stories but his sci-fi is
great Martian Chronicles is great I'm
big Bradbury fan I was looking for
something to read over at the weekend
know over the weekend and so I picked up
the October country which is a book of
his horror stories some of them are
great some of them are not as great but
that's the great thing about short
stories your spend of the 15-20 minutes
on them I love short stories it's sad to
me that short story seems to have fallen
out of fashion and maybe somebody will
bring them back at some point I know
that the the magazine that Bradbury
wrote forward which was called weird
tales I know that it's still around I
have no idea whether it's any good or
not I'd love to see the short story
brought back Ray Bradbury's the October
country but he has a bunch a sound of
thunder is is another short story
collection if you liked Fahrenheit 451
his short stories are of equal quality
you can go check that okay other things
that I like today so this is hilarious a
court a court in the Fifth Circuit Court
of Appeal has now ruled that a federal
prisoner who calls himself a her and
wants to be transferred to a women's
facility if this person appealed to the
court and said I want to be called her
and all the court filings and the court
said no that's giving away the argument
no we're not doing that and this
apparently is very bad because now you
left
like for the courts who engage in
logical inconsistency of going alone
along with the lie that this person is a
woman but then ruling objectively on
whether a woman should be placed with
other women the entire controversy in
this case is over whether this person is
a woman or a man
you can't just grant the premise of the
lawsuit in the lawsuit itself out of
sensitivity
that's absurdity I said this a thousand
times it's amazing people always get my
position on transgender pronouns wrong
because they wish to I've said 1 million
times and if you are at dinner with
somebody and that person wishes to be
called by as a member of the opposite
sex then I'm not gonna go out of my way
just to call the person a member of
their biological sex because why ruin
dinner but when we were talking about
public policy when you're talking about
whether that person actually is a member
of the opposite gender no I'm not gonna
go along with that if I'm in public
debate with the person who's transgender
I'm not going to grant them the premise
that they are a member of the opposite
sex that's the subject of the entire
debate there's a difference between a
public issue and what you say to
somebody in in private at dinner right
if my son wishes for me to call him Luke
Skywalker tonight which he probably does
at home I'll probably do it if I'm on
national TV and he says call me Luke's
Congress ain't no son that's not your
name right I mean that that's not the
way any of this works but according to
the Washington Post supposedly the court
was supposed to go along with the
request to call a him or her and then to
her and then to rule objectively on the
question of whether this him should be
placed as women by the way in this
particular case what the media would
like is for this biological male who is
engaged in pedophilia as why the persons
in prison person was engaged in
trafficking in child pornography they
want the Washington Post columnist
tonight once this person to be labeled a
woman ok ladies if you want that person
labeled a woman have at it
have at it it seems to me that the vast
majority of child pornography charges
accrue to men biology may have something
to do with crime rates when it comes to
male versus female which is why 98
percent of people in prison are male
come on it's just absurd everyone knows
that male aggression and male sex drive
is very different from female which is
why crime rates are different between
male and female duh but we're going to
pretend not for purposes of what
transgender sensitivity absolute silly
towns okay time for good for the Fifth
Circuit Court of Appeal for rejecting
man saying no we're not going to for
the argument out of sensitivity okay
time for a quick thing that I hate so my
home state of California is just turning
into a garbage heap
I've lived here literally my entire life
I think every day now about how long we
can stay here the state of California
has been transformed into homeless
central we have at this point literally
hundreds of thousands of homeless people
living in the state of California you
cannot drive a freeway in Los Angeles
without seeing literal tent cities I
mean I'm talking about full-on tent
cities it looks like Hoovervilles and
governor Gavin Newsom who is a Ken doll
in in every way he is stupid and he is
vacuous and and has that plastered back
hair he was opening a new homeless
facility and he explained that
California has been nowhere to be found
on homelessness weird because it seems
like Jerry Brown was the governor for a
thousand years and then you've been the
governor for a while it seems like every
major city in Los Angeles had been
governed by a Democrat for a very long
time and yet somehow you've gotten no
handle on homelessness not only that
it's gotten massively worse underneath
the Democratic purview here is Gavin
Newsom admitting that he has no idea how
to run his own state let's just be
candid state California's been nowhere
to be found on the dam issue
homelessness we've been focused on this
issue there's a reason things the way
look the way they are it's cuz we
haven't addressed them it's happened on
our watch over the last decade in
particular it's really gotten bad in
last decade and we were just slow to
respond we okay we had a crisis Governor
Brown dan amazing job balancing budget
we were triaging that we we had a lot of
other things to prioritize but got in
the way of our focus on this did an
amazing job balancing the budget the way
the California balanced the budget is by
lying about the accrual of interest in
CalPERS right they they just went to
their their pension funds and then they
suggested that those pension funds were
going to outperform the market by large
percentages and then we wouldn't have to
worry about investing on behalf of those
pension funds so we'd send all these bad
pension contracts Jerry Brown did a
wonderful job balancing the budget he's
raised the top income tax rate to 13.3%
driving business out of the state at
record rates we had a net loss of
population in the state of California I
believe last year
Gavin news sorry we couldn't handle the
homelessness crisis where you have
65,000 people in Los Angeles County
alone who are homeless in the city and
that is very
partially as a result of high housing
prices but the regulations in the city
of Los Angeles making nearly impossible
to build new housing and in large part
that is because the cops have been not
allowed to arrest people for trespass
and also has been tremendous
underfunding of the one thing that the
government ought to fund in the state of
California namely mental health
facilities and drug dry-out facilities
and mandatory drug dry-out
for people who are on the streets
shooting heroin into their feet in front
of businesses I mean you can find open
needles half a block from my house and I
live in a fairly nice area so here in
gavin newsom complain that he's done a
bad job on his on what is his watch they
look the state of california can either
wake up or it can die and right now it
is choosing to die because better to
sleep and pretend that everything is
fine and the weather here is really nice
and we got beaches but the fact is this
state continues to be a garbage heap
Gavin Newsom continues to make it a
garbage heap and we continue to vote
Democrat to make ourselves feel better
even though no Democrat has solved any
of these problems in the last decade or
more it's insane I mean the city of Los
Angeles which I can speak to very
personally cuz I live here Eric Garcetti
who thought about running for president
has been awful every so often right
before there's a photo shoot basically
they'll clean up the streets a little
bit they'll move some of the homeless
people out from underneath the
embankments and then as soon as the as
soon as the media stop covering it those
people are right back there I will say
some of the some of the permanency of
these residences is pretty astonishing
to me the other day right here in Los
Angeles I saw a person who had wired
into you wonder how folks are living on
the streets this person had actually
wired into a street lamp which is pretty
dangerous you shouldn't do this and
wired into a street lamp for electricity
it actually like pulled off the plate at
the base of a street lamp and had wired
into the street lamp and not only had
they wired into the street lamp I saw
that they actually had an old-fashioned
turntable and like an old record player
so we now have hipster homeless people
in the city of Los Angeles we actually
have people who are not satisfied with
the quality of digital music right they
need the original vinyl now listen this
is not to say that these people are not
suffering I think they are suffering I
think it is absolutely unjust and unfair
and not right and disgusting that the
solution of this state and of the city
is to leave them living in their own
filth on street corners and then pretend
that that is what is called freedom it
is not a huge percentage of these folks
are people suffering from mental
a huge percentage of these folks are
people who are suffering from severe
drug addiction leaving them on the
streets to get disease and die is a is a
horrible commentary on what our
government thinks freedom is so
according to the government of the state
of California if you work a job and you
earn then freedom is the government
takes a huge chunk of your salary and
also if you're living on the street in
your own filth because you're mentally
ill or because you have a drug addiction
then freedom is you get to live on your
own and please can't even move you and I
know a lot of members of the LAPD first
of all it is disgusting if they've
turned the LAPD into their solution for
failures to deal with drug addiction and
failures to deal with severe mental
illness okay the police were not
supposed to be first line of response
for people who are mentally ill or drug
addicted
that's absurd they're already stretched
too thin and is not their job and you
wonder how they get into confrontations
with the homeless and then you end up
with bad tape on the news that is
exactly how and that gets a lot worse
when you suggest the police cannot even
move bags of garbage on the street
thanks to ACLU action in the city of Los
Angeles the police could actually be
sued if they move a shopping cart full
of garbage seriously because this has
been declared the personal property of
people living on the streets even though
they're living on the streets that you
and I pay for as taxpayers and provide a
disease threat and provide a violence
threat
how many situations have we had in the
nicer part of the cities I'm talking
about like Hollywood Boulevard like
Hollywood in vine areas of the city that
are tourist centers we've had people who
have been attacked and buckets of hot
feces dumped on their head in the middle
of the city seriously we've had people
stabbed to death in the middle of the
city by homeless folks who are suffering
from severe schizophrenia deep forms of
mental illness drug addiction and the
city's solution is to have gavin newsom
get up there's how well you know I've
been ignoring the problem here's the
bottom line is here's the bottom line
the voters of the state have not forced
Democrats to deal with the problem
because there's no incentive to deal
with the problem all that the Democrats
are elected to do is continue signing
lucrative government contracts with
massive unions who then spend that money
to re-elect the government employees and
grow the bureaucracy and grow the state
a state that does not protect its own
citizens and just drains them dry and
it's gonna get worse it's not gonna get
better the tax rates will continue to go
up the law enforcement will continue to
drop the people stuck in the middle are
the cops and the tax
paying citizens gavin newsom is a
disgrace he'll run for president anyway
in a couple of years if the Democrats
don't win it's just it's it's ridiculous
state this state is on its last legs and
gavin newsom proves it we'll see you
here later today for two additional
hours of content or we'll see you here
tomorrow i'm ben shapiro this is the ben
shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Colton Haas directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer Jonathan hey supervising
producer Mathis Glover and Robert
Stirling assistant director Pavel why
Houston technical producer Austin
Stevens playback and media operated by
Nick's even associate producer Katie
Swinton edited by Adam sy events audio
is mixed by mic poor amina hair and
makeup is by NECA geneva the ben shapiro
show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2025 hey everybody
its Andrew Clavin host of the Andrew
Clavin show you know some people are
depressed because the American Republic
is collapsing the end of days is
approaching and the moon is turned to
blood but on the Andrew Clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over the Andrew Kleber show
and laugh your way through the
apocalypse with me Andrew Clayton
[Music]